I never never been to the circus you've
never been to the circus no no circuses
are
[__] but that's not you took me to a
circus and what happened when you took
me to the circus what happened I left
you there and then two weeks later they
the circus moved to the next town over
and we had to go drive and pick her up
no no is a real
story is that are you crying yeah cuz
it's a horrible memory for her we took
traveled with a circus yes he did and
that's
accidentally accidentally traveled with
the c and it was we didn't realize that
we left her there but then we heard that
the circus was reopening one town over
and I never forget my wife saying look
up on the look up on the trapes the one
with the sparkly suit is that Jackie no
they didn't put me up on the trapes but
they did they did take me to the next
city and they had to come get me did the
show end and they just instantly TR how
long did it realize for you to that you
forgot her that's the saddest part that
I realize now as an adult that it went
like obviously hours before they
realized that I was gone because I went
to the next city and it takes a long
time for them to shut down the circuit
have a lot of kids or no there's only
three of us I'm crying now there's only
three of us now but back then back then
was was it just you uh well we have a uh
the back then was it was it just her
yeah they got no Alex was there too
that's why you took him home was Alex
there yeah you took him home you didn't
take me home H
wow okay Alex was there Riley wasn't
born yet it might be because we have a
younger daughter that wasn't born yet
and then we ended up that's why it
wasn't a week we ended up I I
impregnated her mom for another daughter
because I didn't I didn't real and then
it was too late now he's just joking but
I really was left at the circus and then
you guys picked her up from at the next
city which was far away it wasn't even
in the same state well that's
respectable they drove a while to get
you but the C people are weird because
once you come once somebody's joined the
circus it's really hard to claim them
you can't sit in the audience and go
that one's mine and oh I see what you're
saying it was almost like you had a you
were part of the you were part of they
didn't want to release me to the to like
the wrong people I mean yeah had noble
people yeah circus
people they could have just let her
circus people are weird I'll tell you
I'll be honest with you circus people
are hard to get along with really and
now I'm going to get don't start [__]
with me in the comments circus people
you know you are tough to get along with
and
uh have you ever seen
Cirus I've seen like videos of it on Tik
Tok I haven't you've never seen a Cirus
no oh I never been no it's on my bucket
list it's beautiful they do it with uh
that one has no animals and it's a lot
of uh jumping and twirling and
everything and we took uh we had a uh a
lady that helped us at the house with
the
kids and we so you didn't forget them
sex what her did you forgot who the lady
Stephanie is her name who looked after
our children and we she took we took the
whole family and Stephanie to cir the
S what does that have to do with the
time you left me there why does it
always have to come back it's crazy that
you're still like you would think that
that'd be such a scarring moment that
the whole family be like no more
circuses guys are still going to circus
shows after that for me I would have and
then I'm on AGT now which and a lot of
the performers are circus acts and what
people don't realize when they're
watching me on the show that I have very
a very strong um
reaction because I look at anybody who's
performing who's swinging from the
ceilings or jumping or doing like that
as like somebody who could possibly take
one of my children yeah yeah that's
that's deep I didn't think we were going
to get this deep today well it happens
it did
yeah we're we're um are you sad now I
don't know I just I haven't thought
about it in a really long time yeah
you've been really quiet ever since this
whole circus thing came up I haven't you
haven't really said much well would you
leave one of your kids at a Circ I
wouldn't I wouldn't even go to a circus
first off you don't have kids um
hypothetically if I had kids I wouldn't
go to a circus and then I wouldn't leave
them there so that's just me though I
know some things you just
know are you calling yourself a better
parent than my
dad well technically I'm not a parent so
am I better hypothetical so here's what
happened so here's what happened I went
back and I threatened to sue the circus
you left me there I understand stop it
stop
it the robot just shook her finger at
you okay go
on I uh I spoke to them and uh in order
to avoid a uh lawsuit they presented me
with an
elephant and do you have a picture of me
with the elephant in the
backyard they gave us they gave it they
gave it to you me and my wife you have
here it is that's my
wife hi wife there's the
elephant and there's my wife how we me
that was the tradeoff that was a
trade-off which I got for
uh the picture there it is no is that no
the one in the backyard where's the one
in the
backyard there's an elephant in my
backyard I don't know I'll put It Up's
no picture you took you took so you took
her and the Elephant home no I took the
elephant home where where you pointing
well that one on YouTube kind of shows
it in our backyard oh there but that's
you don't want to play the video no we
don't have to but but just show the
still the the Conan still you can see me
at the see that where it says Conan see
what says Conan that's me telling Conan
about how I got the the see the elephant
that's in my backyard there what the
hell is going on is this real I don't
know what like when when when you guys
are telling the truth or what's a lie
you you really brought you got an
elephant yeah okay this is pretty
[Music]
wild
d